[Music]
hey Colonel Brian here you know the
Superbowl has many celebrated traditions
but no Super Bowl tradition is more
revered more time-honored than this one
to NFL Super Bowl athletes playing video
games with me in a cheap mariette
conference Roman I'm joined tonight by
Josh Norman from the Carolina Panthers
von Miller from the Denver Broncos
tonight we're playing doom I got to
confess on a Patriots fan of from Boston
you personally beat up badly on my
quarterback Tom Brady you made my
twelve-year-old daughter cry oh how do
you sleep at night
it's just a game one of your dreams is
to have a poultry farm is that right yes
sir have a commercial farms all over TV
I'm on commercials you want a whole
bunch of farms and you want to have V
commercials yeah TV commercials I wanna
have a live feed inside the cages well
you see how happy my chickens are that's
a great advertisement our chickens are
so good you can go on to even watch live
life living a good life in the Google
just before you eat it
all right Josh you've taken some improv
right yeah you got it you got some
pretty good improv skills a little some
song let's do a quick scene right now
hello sir welcome to my ice-cream shop
well less alright I think we should play
Doom nice sometimes when you sack some
of these blow up
it's a hologram it's a hologram how did
you know that was a hologram
I mean I'd seen two part in coaching I
got a compliment you on the fashion
you've been rocking [ __ ] you've been
doing an amazing job Josh can you pull
off what Vaughn what Vaughn pulls off it
can I say something
you're my two best friends in the whole
world head buddies yeah the Hat buds man
I was a little hard but you just didn't
feel good when you did that right could
you feel the bones giving away I'm an
old man
[Laughter]
okay it's been pretty violent pretty
intense I think we need a cool-down
moment you guys cool with that I'm cool
with it alright okay okay this is a hook
and ladder Pinot Noir just let that
breathe for a second what are you
tasting there
oh man I'm not really a one organic my
life is before they murder me and I
haven't seen to panco chili I'm gonna
have someone sub for me for a second
okay is that Alright yeah can I have
someone sub for me yes I'm not so good
at this game my friend could you step in
here and take over for me please
game you just kill and kill and kill
what's that who's that guy it don't
matter he didn't flush they told me they
knew he was gonna be out here for the
silver ball so if you come through
opening your street passes accept it
really
street cred in Oakland no car nice
living
okay okay you don't have to shoot him
he'll die of diabetes in about a year
[Music]
this sounds like kool-aid the hardest
level now Vaughn you ready to go yep and
we're gonna have a contest to see what
you've you guys can last the longest and
go 49 seconds how you feelin how do you
feel about that Vaughn it's tough man I
stuff I feel pretty good about Josh this
is a tough moment for you
you got to last longer than 49 seconds
you got strategy go
[Music]
I'm way to get like 40 all right you win
now you get to go and kill hey Phil the
winner fun I'd like to say it was you
but you did not have the winning time
Marshawn you're not even supposed to be
here I don't know who let you in Josh
your method was to cheat but your
strategy worked
you are the Conan coolest gamer
[Applause]
okay the game is doom and it comes out
on May 13th you guys like it look great
you liked it oh all right and
congratulations to my two Africans
reason is sorry I actually toasted in on
the aggregate
[Applause]
[Music]
hey thanks for watching click here to
check out last year's Superbowl edition
of clueless gamer